i think my favorite part about being gay  is that um  i don't have to follow the rules  like there's a lot of rules you got to  follow when you're a man when you're  like a straight man you got to be manly  you got not me i'm free i can do this  look at me  i can wear i can wear earrings  men can't wear earrings but they can  wear watches because time is straight  but sound is gay  it's like who made these rules you can't  wear shorts that are too short those are  gay long shorts those are cool but  capris are gay pants are straight pants  suits are lesbian and theater is gay but  if you're in your underwear it's  wrestling  who's got time to memorize these 300  years ago they were opposite  like men wear heels and wigs and makeup  heels wigs makeup  i'm sorry if george washington were here  today ross matthews would take one look  at him like we need that queen on drag  race  legs for days beat to the gods  sure she doesn't have teeth but honey  she has charisma